hello everyone today my channel reached
400,000 subscribers and I would like to
thank you all for all of your warm and
hardly congratulations what we are going
to revisit that in my next video where
we're going to be showing a nice style
game as it is customary on this channel
for this video as promised I decided to
show a very nice game played by Robert
Shanta it's the last game he ever played
for those of you who follow my other
social media might have seen that
unfortunately yesterday the gentleman
passed away at the age of 44 so this is
a game from the creation League he plays
against the middle of arena I would also
like to thank you thank me result [ __ ]
enough for sending me this game as the
games play there are not published
online so thanks very much for that and
it's a it's a very nice line of the
Berlin defence where white just creates
a creates a nice attack seemingly out of
nothing and well you just have to have
to see it's to enjoy it so without
further ado hunter has the white pieces
and he opens with E 4 we have E 5 by
Black Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 rule opus is on the board
and hoary now replies with Knight to f6
saw the Berlin defence D 3 will be 6 now
not the modern Bishop to c5 that
everyone plays these days but still a
standard line with castles Bishop to e7
by horn ah h3 hindering the development
of the of the dark square Bishop and
also may be preparing g4 in the future
we have castles by black c3 making room
for the bishop on c2 a 6 but a 4 B 5 and
Bishop to see - we've looked to e8 a
standard move in the Brillion making
room for the bishop the common e8 and
the rook on f8 and the rook will now be
controlling the e-file
supporting the 5 point if black ever
decides to push d5
we have rook to e1 by white and here
it's a very standard position a lot of
the players have reached this position
in their games for example in 2012
vasily von Schuch had this position with
the white pieces against the creation of
the secret and where's the secret and
played Bishop to b7 in the bunch won a
very nice game also unknown game
Fedorchak versus even cherish were even
charge played d5 in 2013 that game ended
in a draw but here we have eight-six
it's not a new move in the position but
it's one that is a mmm
well rarely played and hereafter night
beat the D to the standard line well the
center idea in the real hope is you want
to go night to f1 and maybe to e3 or g3
depending on what by place and it is as
of this moment as of move 11 that we
have now a new game but up to afaik a
standard move just making room for the
rook and not nice to f1 as planned with
Bishop to b7 and now that the bishop is
developed this way the bishop is mean
caret the bishop no longer controls the
king side here you could play something
standard like a for maybe a nice flank
attack on the on the Queen side but here
Shanta decides to go for g4 he's
preparing g5 and he wants to start a
king set attack even though he himself
Castle kingside or maybe
aside from that just also taking a very
nice control of the f5 square knot is
coming to g3 to f5 and if black wants to
prevent that he will have to further
weaken the king side by playing g6 we
have d5 a nice principled response from
Horan up as if you are attacked on the
King side you should reply by by an
attack in the center Queen to e2 adding
another a defender to d4 pawn and also
getting the Queen away from the D file
we have D captures pawn captures and now
Queen to e7 black does the same also he
wants to get his other look into the
game and now Knight the g3 the knight
wants to come to a5 which is an
excellent outpost for tonight this will
be a monster night so of course Horner
has to prevent that he plays g6 and now
Shanta starts the attack
we have g5 h captors and g5 with Bishop
captures and g5 now nicely painting the
knight and Bishop to g7 defending the
knight yet again and also the queen is
coming to East 6 so now the knight will
be able to move with H for preparing h5
and not winter e6 now if the point is
pushed to h5 tonight we'll be able to
capture as it is no longer pinned and
here
the h2 controlling the g4 square but
also kind of allowing the Queen to
infiltrate we are Queen to h3 so tonight
to h7 as the night is no longer pin that
the bishop is now under attack we have
first Bishop to b3 attacking the Queen
and if the Queen moves away from the
defense of the f7 pawn queen to f3 is
the idea piling up on the f7 pawn and
maybe if the row comes to d1 also the
row can get to d7 if black doesn't
counter the white rook along the D file
with Queen to h3 and now comes Queen to
f3 now the bishop and queen are piling
up on the f7 pawn and well black has to
decide what to do here first Knight
captures on g5 getting rid of one of the
attackers while defending the f7 pawn
from g5 we have H capture sin g5 and now
now just Knights to d8 defending the f7
pawn which is which is a must but on the
other hand your looks are no longer
connected and for the moment the a8 rook
is not not able to enter the game so
Robbie immediately takes advantage of
this he goes rook a to d1 now preparing
rook to b7 and now rook to e7 preventing
rook to d7 but looked rook to e7 while
it does prevent rook to d7 and also it
adds another defender to the f7 pawn
there was also the idea of rook captures
night
so another defender of the f7 point is
much needed but it doesn't work here
White has an excellent tactic I'll give
you a couple of seconds try to figure
out what will be played here as it is
the only move that gives a white
advantage I'll give you a couple of
seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you're once again an
excellent tactician and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
Knight to f5 which is just a wonderful
idea even though black tried to prevent
Knight from reaching the f5 square white
the white knight finds itself under very
nice outpost so here's the threat Knight
captures rook that's one threat Queen
captures Queen that's the second threat
and how do you prevent both threats if
you move the rook you lose the Queen if
you play something like Queen captures
Queen then the problem is first white
captures the rook with check after the
King moves you will first grab another
pawn with check and then after only
after this is captured Knight captures
here and at the end of this very nice
line white is up the exchange and up a
pawn so an easily winning endgame for
white so what's the idea here after
Knight to f5 what can black play
well once again now feel free to pause
the video and try to find the only good
response from blacks perspective also a
very nice idea maybe even pause the
video sure for those of you who are able
to do it once again a top tactician and
for those of you who just wanna enjoy
show notice that the bishop is x-raying
the Queen over there over the long
diagonal and if the na this pawn ever
moves the Bishop can capture the Queen
so the only move here is Queen captures
Knight on f5 this is what holding a
plate and it is by far the best move we
have it captures by Shanta Bishop
captures Queen now an f3 Knight captures
Bishop and now G captures an f5 and here
just nitrate for black has a very nice
pawn mass here so you do want to do
something about it now black black can
try to defend the pawn but it will cost
in precious time here f4 is played not
allowing whites to capture but just
Knight to f5 now attacking the bishop
and the rook so what do you do here we
have rook to e8 as there is no danger of
capturing on f7 for the moment and now
finally the rook is able to infiltrate
via rook to d7 so what you play here
it's a very very tough position you
might think okay I'll give up the c5
pawn is it a c7 for maybe I'll go look
at fate and now I'll be able to move
mine
but it doesn't work here white would
have this very nice 97 check and now
whatever we go King h8 or King h7 just a
nice check you force the King back and
now King G do there is no good defense
against rook to h1 this is just over
white is completely winning here so here
after look to the 7 black tried c5 he
wants to play c4 cut off the attack from
the light square Bishop towards the f7
pawn
so first Bishop to d5 not allowing c4 to
close the bishop in and also not wasting
time as it does come with an attack
against the rook we have rook to b8 by
black and now g6 finally so now the pawn
is pinned attacked by the rook and now
you attack it again black cannot add
another defender after the f7 pawn or he
can but then he faces some other ideas
rook to f8 is played adding another
defender but now just G captures an f7
you might think but why not 97 again
it's a bit different now if 97 now then
King h8 and now if you go King to g2 you
are preparing rook to H 1 of course but
black can go Bishop h6 and although
white is still winning here you can go
King g7 make some room for the king and
it would perhaps take a bit more time so
Robbie goes for the quickest idea G
captures on f7 with the check and now
you could go King h7 only then will why
to go for this line King G 2 followed by
rope to H 1 so here black tried
capturing the pawn we have Knight
captures on f7 and now adding another
attacker towards the f7 night as the
knight is pinned just Knight to d6 and
here there's a triple attack you are
you're not able to add any more
defenders to the f7 night so here rook F
to DA displayed it would the idea that
if rook captures then rook captures on
d6 and although there are a lot of ideas
here you could go just capture rook and
then win this guy or you could just
capture here with check immediately but
Robbie goes for the for the nicest line
we have rook captures allow and group
captures on d6
look at recently success played and now
just rook to d7 check forcing a
discovery and now black will either lose
a whole rook or here
to give up the exchange we have look out
for some d5 rook a person d5 attacking
the c5 pawn and the now just rip the c8
so here it's a black is up upon but
white is up the exchange with a much
better position so he starts bringing
the King into the game this is something
you always want to do in an endgame
kingi to him the king wants to come up
all the way we have looked the c6 and
now King to f3 Bishop to f6 and now rook
eat a d1 doubling up on D file rock to
d6 is the idea with the attack against
the bishop hoping to trade rooks and if
the rook moves of course there's always
the a6 pawn king to f7 defending now
rook to d6 you can't really afford to
trade rooks so rook to see it displayed
and our aerobic read grabs yet another
pawn rook captures on a6 is played King
to g6 and now King to e4 King is coming
over to the Queen side to gobble up all
of the pawns help out the rook we have
before and here rook D to d6 and it was
in this position that made us all Haruna
are resigned to the game what if you
resign well there's really nothing more
to do here your Bishop is under attack
you have to defend it after Luke to f8
white can play pretty much any move and
it will be winning let's say a 4 you
just create a nice pass pawn captures
captures and well black will be helpless
to defend against this something like
King g7 you if we try to unpin white
white can even go as far as just giving
up in the rooks for for the rook and
Bishop and push a 4 and it will be
completely winning we can even show it
as it's you know I no brainer you can
just push the pawn king b6 a6
king c6 you can just go a 7 and after
king b7 now go King D 5 you get rid of
the points and that's about it
captures captures efore now King goes
here if you push III captures black can
fly everybody doesn't work just kingly
three stay in the side inside of the
square of the pawn and whatever black
place like the King b7 e for now you can
go King c6 now comes King III King c5
you can capture the pawn and now here's
the problem it's the standard endgame
where white the white pawns are
separated one square apart and they are
creating a wall against the black King
so the black King can approach the C
pawn but it doesn't matter
White's just gonna ignore him and you
will never be able to capture the pawn
once you capture it you can no longer
catch up to the passed pawn
so all also an interesting thing to
consider it doesn't matter where the
white king is the white king can be
after he captured a pawn it doesn't
matter if it's on h1 but it's important
that the two points create a wall
against the black king when there are 1
square apart so also we can learn
something from this but both aerobic and
and miroslav knew this so after rugby 36
meters lorina resigned the game so I
wonderful a wonderful game by Robert
Shanta the last game he ever played a
few weeks ago in in the creation League
very nice victory against the brilliant
defense and against Miroslav who is who
is a very strong player and once again I
would like to thank him for sending me
the pigeon the moves of the game as I
don't think I would be able to acquire
them otherwise so really I mean it was a
really sad day yesterday I didn't record
any videos and I'm not all that
surprised people died I'm not surprised
by that but it's just a just really a
huge loss for the world as he was a he
was a wonderful person and really just a
great guile and all but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Brock remaining
Christopher Casella Federico Sami Sami
tur Ludovic Laurent and CC best pro for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos here I think all for watching and
I will see you soon with the celebratory
tall game for you know commemorating the
the 400,000 subscribers milestone where
I will inform you about - what what
happens next
thank you all and I will see you soon